ce soir c'est la saison des impôts on
vous présente une édition spéciale de
son économie
que devez-vous savoir quels sont les
changements qui auront un impact sur vos
impôts
vous avez un faible revenu vous avez
tout intérêt à faire votre déclaration
de revenus empreinte indique t on pas un
timbre de répondre à nos questions puis
de 2,9 elle en dirait et ont touché une
copie de leur rapport d'un pool
vous êtes travailleurs autonomes semi
retraités ou retraités on a des conseils
pour vous ce soir et tout au long de
cette émission on va répondre à vos
questions vous êtes maintenant en somme
économie
[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes heureux de vous
retrouver et de présenter de nouveau
cette année une édition spéciale impôts
de zone économie c'est devenu une
véritable tradition comme la saison des
impôts qui revient comme chaque année
avec l'arrivée du printemps nous avons
un menu quand même très chargé pour vous
ce soir on va parler de l'impôt des
moins nantis des plus riches aussi des
retraités des parents et toute la
journée avec l'appui des étudiants de la
maîtrise en fiscalité de l'université de
sherbrooke on a répondu à vos questions
sur notre site web des centaines de
questions des centaines de réponses que
vous pouvez déjà retrouver sur radio
canada.ca par oblique impôts avec un s
2022 andréanne bonsoir c'est d'autres
aides joue d'entrée de jeu avec vous on
va faire un petit tour d'horizon qui
sont les contribuables et qui paie de
l'impôt des contribuables il y en a un
petit peu plus de 30 millions dans
l'ensemble du canada alors c'est à eux
qu'on s'adresse ce soir je suis
convaincu qu'ils sont tous en train de
regarder on est que nous mais qu bon
blague à part ça représente à peu près
80% de la population les autres bons ne
sont pas considérés contribuables
souvent parce qu'ils sont trop jeunes ou
d'autres types de situations mais 30
millions de personnes qui sont
assujettis à l'impôt mais qui en
fonction de leur situation finiront par
payer ou non des sommes au fisc ce qui
me permettent de vous rappeler qu'il ya
une bonne portion de la population qui
génèrent des revenus très limité ça
c'est le bilan pour le québec je suis
vous mentionne que les pourcentages sont
similaires pour l'ensemble du canada que
ça se maintient d'une année à l'autre
alors c'est un petit peu plus du tiers
de la population qui génèrent des
revenus de moins de 25 mille dollars et
29 % génère des revenus entre 25 et 50
mille dollars donc déjà remarqué que ces
deux sections la en bleu et en rouge à
droite c'est à peu près les deux tiers
de la population donc qui génère moins
de 50000 $ 15 % en génère des revenus
entre 50 et 70 mieux de la 11 mai 11 %
jusqu'à 100000 et 9% de plus de 100000
dollars alors surtout ces contribuables
qui paient de l'impôt il y en a une
bonne portion qui n'en paient pas c'est
à peu près 30 6% qui n'en paient tout
simplement pas ça veut dire deux
millions et demi de personnes à peu près
au québec et 10 millions de personnes au
canada et à linverse 64% ou ils paient
de l'impôt souvent ce sont des
travailleurs entre 45 64 ans qui sont en
pleine carrière et des réchauds si les
20% les plus riches qui déclare à peu
près la moitié de tous les revenus
déclarés paix 66% de l'impôt perçu par
québec pour l'impôt des particuliers
alors c'est quand on entre dans le
détail là que ça devient un petit peu
plus complexe on adore on a bradé du
contenu concret la supra l'ordre de 35 à
40% qui paient pas d'impôts c'est à peu
près la même chose dans toutes les
pauvres dans toutes les provinces dans
l'ensemble du canada et d'une année à
l'autre ça se maintient ce pourcentage
est notre émission va être utile à
beaucoup de monde aujourd'hui parce que
la plupart des gens n'ont pas encore
soumis leur déclaration de revenus mais
on ne peut pas encore parler de
retardataires évidemment parce qu'il
reste à peu près un mois encore mais
dernier bilan de l'agencé du revenu du
canada ce qu'on observe en fait c'est
que c'est à peu près 8 million deux cent
mille déclaration de revenus qui ont été
arrêtées jusqu'à maintenant c'est de
manière assez général de manière
électronique que ça a été soumis 94% et
les deux tiers des gens qui ont déjà
soumis leurs déclarations ont eu droit à
un remboursement en moyenne de 2000 $ et
les autres ont eu un seul moyen à payer
2 4330 dollar ça concerne à peu près 17
% des contribuables qu'il y avait un
seul à payer alors justement des
conseils ce soir pour maximiser votre
remboursement réduire la facture
d'impôts j'ai fait d'autres déclarations
de revenus pour encore nombreux non plus
viendra few mais j'attendais l'émission
pour avoir des conseils voilà vous allez
tout savoir et vous allez pouvoir faire
ça en fin de semaine andré hommes merci
attendent aussi beaucoup à tantôt alors
est-ce que vos impôts se sont bien
utiliser notre question du jour vos
impôts sont ils bien utilisé faites-nous
connaître votre point de vu son économie
à commercial radio canada.ca
à chaque année les gouvernements
annoncent des changements qui complique
peut-être un peu notre vie et la
déclaration d'impôts le goût de boue est
avec nous devons soir le goût de bonsoir
le blues est le titulaire de la chaire
en fiscalité finances publiques de
l'université de sherbrooke ce sont vos
étudiants aujourd'hui qui nous ont aidés
à répondre aux questions du public ça
s'est bien passé oui ça s'est bien passé
mais c'est un travail qui est quand même
exigeant donc les étudiants plusieurs
dizaines d'étudiants et une dizaine de
professeurs ont contribué harang de
l'exercice possible et ça s'est fait par
jaume
c'est par tim cette année donc les
étudiants sont les connecter 3,4 à la
fois avec un professeur pour les
accompagner dans l'exercice tout le long
de la journée alors on y remercie
d'ailleurs parce qu'on a reçu des
centaines de questions au cours de la
journée et ce sont ces personnes qui ont
pris le temps de répondre aux questions
du public voilà voilà et on les remercie
vraiment vous avez combien d'étudiants
on a 90 étudiants à temps plein ok ok
donc commençons on veut savoir le crédit
de 500 $ le fameux qui le dit 500
dollars que doivent faire les
contribuables pour avoir leurs crédits
de 500 $
riez parfait on passait notre temps mais
ont rien à faire donc même ceux qui
avaient déjà produit avant l'annoncé ils
vont recevoir
un dépôt direct oui donc la déclaration
vont être corrigés et ceux qui n'ont pas
produit ont rien à faire non plus parce
que ça va être pris en compte au moment
de la production alors il ya beaucoup de
gens qui nous disent où est ce que
j'écris ou est-ce que je peux déduire
moi même mon 500 $ si j'ai un solde à
payer vous n'avez rien à vous n'avez
rien à faire techniquement
moi si j'ai ma déclaration à faire et
j'ai un seul de 1200 à payer puis on est
le 2 avril peu de prendre la décision
d'envoyer 700 et en disant ça va s'auto
réguler mais le revenu québec d'y
envoyer votre montant on va vous
renvoyez montant l'a fait parfait une
fois les vérifications faites excellent
nouveautés maintenant changement pour le
crédit d'impôt pour frais de garde au
québec oui donc c'est des changements
qui ont été annoncées en la mise à jour
de novembre
2021 mais ça prenait effet pour toute
l'année 2000 21 heures donc
on va parler de la copie pour commencer
semblant on va y aller dans l'ordre donc
le changement pour le crédit d'impôt
pour frais de garde donc tout à fait
donc le crédit le taux était majoré
avant le taux était de 75 % pour les
revenus les plus faibles jusqu'à 26 pour
ça il était majoré à 78 % lorsqu'on a
des revenus assez faible donc de 21000
ou moins et par la suite le taux minimal
maintenant est rendu à 67% je donne un
exemple une famille qui faisait à 75000
avant ça lave un taux de 60 maintenant
on va avoir un taux de 70 une famille
qui fait 175 mètres donc devenir revenus
plus élevés avant celle avec un taux de
26 elle va maintenant avoir un taux de
67 donc tout le monde a vu leur taux
aussi et on a même eu aussi le montant
les dépenses admissibles par enfant
nourri tout aussi à 10400 pour 2021 dans
le fond ce qu'on cherche à faire c'est
ceux qui n'ont pas de places dans les
garderies à contribution réduite on veut
qu'on finance et une plus grande part
des coûts de garde de cette façon là ok
ça c'est le premier changement autre
changement le crédit d'impôt pour le
soutien aux aînés pour du côté du québec
a été bonifié c'est une nouvelle mesure
qui existe depuis 2018 ou 2019 donc pour
2021 le montant maximum pour un aîné de
70 ans et plus aurait dû être de 209
dollars la mise à jour économique encore
une fois le aussi à 400 $ par année de
70 ans et plus par contre c'est pas
toutes les années qu'il y ont droit il
faut avoir
des revenus quand même assez modestes et
les personnes seules qui ont un revenu
de 31 8 575 ou plus n'ont pas droit de
la prestation et pour les coupes ça faut
avoir un revenu inférieur à 50 3340 pour
avoir droit totalement ou partiellement
à ce montant là autre changement qu'on
surveille de près en fait je vous pose
la question est ce qui est des
changements par rapport au télétravail
par rapport au télétravail il ya une
méthode qui avait été fait l'année
passée qui s'appelait la méthode
simplifiée cette méthode là se poursuit
ces deux dollars par jour dont une qui a
pas de changement sauf que en 2020 comme
la pandémie avait débuté en cours donné
on avait droit - moins grand nombre de
jours ça donne un total de maximale de
400 $ cette année le maximum ses 500 $ 2
dollars par jour la méthode simplifiée
on n'a pas de formulaire on n'a pas de
formulaire à fournir par contre on veut
aller dans la méthode détaillée las
après un formulaire de l'employeur et
vous conservez ces reçus c'est plus
complexe ok et donc on rappelle quand
même que cette méthode simplifiée
s'applique pour tous les types de
télétravailleurs depuis deux ans là oui
c'est ça va s'appliquer y ont déjà nous
et 2022 il y aura encore droit pour les
portions où on est obligé de faire du
télétravail en raison de la coved
parlant de la coved il ya des gens qui
ont touché des prestations et pour
certains ils n'avaient pas droit aux
presque si on devait rembourser comment
ça fonctionne mais pour ceux qui
devaient rembourser
donc il ya un choix qui est possible
vous avez eu des prestations en 2020 et
vous les avez remboursé en 2021 on vous
laisse le choix de dire que vous allez
cas que j'ai 2020 pour effacer les
montants reçus en trop ou vous dites je
vois plutôt qu'au rejet 2021 et je vais
avoir moins d'impôts à payer en 2021
alors il ya comme un petit planification
là pour ont choisi ce qui est plus
avantageux mais le fisc vous laisse
choisir
parfait du côté fédéral le crédit
d'impôt pour les fournitures scolaires a
été bonifié pour les fournitures
scolaires effectivement c'est un crédit
le kéké nez c'était justin trudeau qui
l'avait annoncé aux élections de 2015
donc c'est un crédit qui pour les
enseignants et lors des dernières
élections le toit était majoré c'était
entre en vigueur avec la mise à jour
économique de l'automne au fédéral de 15
à 25% pour l'année 2020 terrain de taux
a été majorée et on a ajouté de
nouvelles dépenses admissibles donc on
maintenant d'un enseignant qui peut être
lui même de sa poche des calculatrices
des webcams des ordinateurs avant ça
c'était plus limité aux ciseaux au
crayon au papier l'europe c'est des
dépenses maximale de 1000 $ on a élargi
les dépenses on élargit les dépenses
pour ne majorer le taux essentiellement
ok peut-être un dernier mot sur les
droits de cotisation reér revenus de
bourses de perfectionnement post
doctoral donc pour les bourses
postdoctorales avant ça c'était habitat
pas considéré comme du revenu gagné aux
fins du réel on a élargi effectivement
maintenant on dit des revenus de bourses
postdoctorales ça va ça va donner droit
des cotisations réel au pied on peut
même corriger les années passent et si
on a eu des revenus de bourse sont soit
coach ça ok vous faites votre
déclaration de revenus vous jeux
présents fait pour beaucoup j'en fais 6
celle donnée deux vieux parents celle de
mes deux jeunes enfants qui ont qui ont
18 ans ainsi que celle de ma conjointe
est la mienne et vous aimez ça j'aime ça
courrier ou par fait plaisir l'année
passée j'ai même fait faire celle de mes
enfants eux mêmes en instruments les
déclarations pour qu'ils puissent voir
qu'est ce qu'on doit faire à chaque
ligne et se poser plein de questions et
on trouvait ça un peu angoissant j'ai
complété la déclaration moi même par
l'esm quand le godbout vous surveiller
en train de faire votre déclaration de
revenu saas peut vous trouviez ça
angoissant quand même merci de consulter
le coin tôt
que devez-vous savoir si vous êtes
retraités ou semi-retraités au moment de
faire votre déclaration de revenus
crédit d'impôt supplément de revenu
garanti projets dans tous les détails à
18h30 heure de l'est
depuis plusieurs personnes qui ont un
très bas salaires pourraient être tentés
de ne pas faire leur déclaration de
revenus ce n'est pas une bonne idée
marie-claude parce qu'en ne faisant pas
leurs déclarations ces personnes
risquent de perdre beaucoup d'argent
c'est important de remplir sa
déclaration de revenus pour accumuler
des droits de cotisation réa mais aussi
pour aller chercher tous les crédits
d'impôt disponible
les allocations familiales l'aide aux
loyers pour les retraités à faibles
revenus le supplément de revenu garanti
je sais que certaines personnes trouvent
soit compliqué mais il ya des solutions
et il ya entre autres des cliniques
d'impôt si votre situation est assez
simple si vos revenus sont modestes
il y en a un peu partout au pays si vous
tapez sur internet gouvernement du
canada comptoir d'impôt vous allez
tomber sur un répertoire vous allez
pouvoir fouiller par municipalité selon
vos besoins et vous devrions trouver une
quand même assez près de chez vous c'est
sûr que la plupart d'entre elles sont
encore un virtuel que ce soit par
vidéoconférence téléphone ou dépôt de
documents il y en a aussi qui ont renoué
avec le présentiel c'est le cas de
l'organisme que j'ai visités à
châteauguay
voilà une bonne chose de réglée pour
madame bergeron
ces impôts sont faits j'ai fait
bénévolement qui ont un très bon service
avec toutes ces messieurs dames qui vont
des impôts les membres d'impôt bénévoles
du suroît remplit chaque année plus de
1000 déclarations de revenus après deux
ans virtuel ils sont de retour en
présentiel avec une douzaine de journées
comme celle-ci on leur a offert pendant
deux ans et demi de faire ça par
téléphone
ils sont mal à l'aise c'est ce qu'ils
ont de la misère à nous fournir les
renseignements qui ont en avant deux ans
pour les autres les ya mieux arriver ici
avec leurs papiers les gouvernements
subventionnent des centaines
d'organismes communautaires pour qu'ils
organisent des cliniques des banques
pour les gens faibles revenus certains
organismes demandent une contribution
souvent entre 5 et 10 dollars alors que
d'autres comme ici ne demande rien c'est
complètement reçu un autre qui nous
sommes d'argent pour le refuge pour
bénéficier des services d'une clinique
d'impôt le revenu maximal est de 35000
dollars pour une personne seule et de
45000 pour un adulte avec un enfant ou
pour un couple
la limite aux demandes de 2500 pour
chaque personne à charge supplémentaire
c'est du bénévolat puis c'est pour les
gens faibles revenus
je déjà venu ici puis font du bon
travail je suis proche de chez moi puis
parce qu'on peut y porter ce soir nous
sommes classés par bagdad en général le
dossier sera entièrement réglé
directement sur place empruntant des
écoutes et en pente
répondre à la question puis de faire en
direct non pas à revenir ils y ont tous
eu une copie de leur apport d'un pool
pichard sillage web j ai pu même au
niveau de tps tvq les bénéficiaires
doivent avoir une situation fiscale
simple ils ne peuvent pas par exemple
être travailleur autonome ou avoir
déclaré faillite absolue mais c'est pas
trop compliqué mais accepter qu'un qui
en a qui arrivent avec des enfants il à
faire là et c'est plus long mais sa voix
c'est bien on a un logiciel qui est très
performant
il a déménagé depuis quelle date les
bénévoles reçoivent une formation du
gouvernement chaque année et dispose
d'une ligne directe pour poser leurs
questions fonctionnaires ils peuvent
aussi se tourner vers leurs collègues
qui ont souvent beaucoup d'expérience si
j'adore faire les impôts puis j'apprends
beaucoup c'est une passion que j'ai fait
cinquante ans que j'en ferais pas que je
me dis pourquoi pas donner mon temps des
gens certains usagers ont pris un peu
parfois même beaucoup de retard avec
leurs impôts dudit rapport d'impôt à
faire des fois j'en ai rien il ya une
méconnaissance andokoi ajouté chaleur
dernier 800 comptes ensemble de droits
que en personne non pas revenir lyon
toute l'information people ont eu du bon
travail et vie
ici marie claude morin radio-canada
château guide
très très intéressant on va maintenant
parler d'une autre catégorie de
contribuables bonsoir mathieu 11 ans
gérald alors il ya beaucoup de gens
parmi les plus fortunés de notre société
qui ne peut pas les taux d'imposition
les plus élevés expliquez nous pourquoi
d'abord les gens fortunés vise deux
choses ans et de réduire ou je me trompe
s'y essaie de réduire c'est de réduire
voilà sassari réduire le revenu
imposable et de reporter de l'impôt à
payer à plus tard on pense ici au
concept du reér alors ce que j'ai fait
c'est que j'ai demandé à l'ush morin qui
est fiscaliste et auteur du rapport du
livre la b6 de l'entrepreneur passionné
pour savoir comment ça fonctionne et
souvent ce que les dirigeants
d'entreprises et les professionnels
comme les avocats les médecins vont
faire c'est de se créer un axe constitué
un hic une entreprise et si cette
personne reçoit des revenus annuels de
500 mille dollars eh bien on va verser
ça dans la société dans l'entreprise où
on va retenir trois cent cinquante mille
dollars desquels on va déduire certaines
dépenses par exemple la voiture on aura
un taux d'impôt de 25 pour ça mais faut
vivre gérad alors on a deux options soit
le salaire ou les dividendes si c'est le
salaire on ira chercher ici dans ce
cas-ci 150 mille dollars on voit encore
faire des déductions par exemple reér il
peut y en avoir d'autres et on a un taux
d'imposition effectif de plus ou moins
30 % et en plus ont pu bénéficier
d'allocations familiales si la personne
avait décidé de ne rien faire et prendre
les 500 mille dollars il y avait eu un
taux d'impôt moyen d'à peu près 47 48%
donc vous voyez ici la différence
combien elle peut être importante c'est
comme ça que ça fonctionne mais
évidemment avec la société
éventuellement il va falloir retirer
l'argent de là pour vivre l'art de la
retraite et là il y aura encore de
l'impôt à payer voici le sme aurait pas
de solution magique mais ce qu'on veut
dans le fond quand on veut économiser de
l'impôt c'est soit reporter l'impôt ou
soit diminuer notre venue imposable ou
avoir plus de dépenses déductibles se
veut diminuer la charge fiscale soit qui
veut diminuer le plus possible des
revenus qui vont certains rapports
d'impôts c'est la base pour tout le
monde
[Musique]
et il ya d'autres stratégies
d'optimisation fiscale bien entendu on
peut penser tout simplement au celi est
revenu de placement immobilier où on a
une imposition sur 50% du gain en
capital les revenus locatifs avec les
dépens à ses intérêts déductibles
déduction pour travailleurs autonomes
exonération des gains en capital de près
de 900 mille dollars lors de la vente
d'une petite entreprise lors de la vente
des actions d'une petite entreprise vous
entendu dire optimisation fiscale tout
ça est ce que c'est de l'optimisation de
l'évitement fiscal ça tombe davantage
dans l'optimisation fiscale l'évitement
fiscal c'est davantage quand vous avez
de l'abus de droit quand ya de la
mauvaise foi mais retenez que plus vous
avez de l'argent plus vous avez
d'options
civilisation fiscale c'est la capacité
donc de d'utiliser des situations
fiscales des privilèges fiscaux qui sont
prévues par la loi sauf que pour en
bénéficier généralement il faut avoir
des moyens de les acheter ces privilèges
fiscaux là les personnes plus démunies
dans nos pôles et moyer
puisqu'on parle du 1 % quelle est sa
contribution à ce 1% bien la voici ses
17% des impôts payés par les
particuliers au québec soixante-huit
personnes revenu médian d'environ 367
1000 $ et s'est représenté
principalement par des hommes à 72 pour
ça merci beaucoup monsieur très
intéressant merci
après la pause qu'est ce que vous devez
savoir si vous avez gagné ou perdu de
l'argent en investissant dans l'équipe
tout monnaie et plus tard combien vous
reste-t-il dans vos poches lorsque vous
recevez une augmentation de salaire
[Musique]
cette saison des impôts est une grande
source de stress pour les contribuables
canadiens un sondage h&r block révèle
que la moitié des canadiens sont
inquiets parce que les prestations liées
à la coved 19 les aides face à
l'inflation et les déductions pour le
télétravail complique énormément les
calculs en fait quarante pour cent des
canadiens disent n'avoir aucune idée
s'ils recevront un remboursement ou
s'ils auront un solde à payer et dans un
tel cas le quart des contribuables
disent ne pas avoir les moyens de faire
un chèque au gouvernement pour faciliter
ses calculs l' agence du revenu du
canada a homologué pas moins d'une
quarantaine de logiciels différents dont
16 sont offerts gratuitement
chaque année près de 3 millions de
contribuables ne produisent pas leur
déclaration de revenus ce qui les prive
souvent de prestations de centaines
voire de milliers de dollars
[Musique]
on poursuit cette édition spéciale avec
myriam smir s qui est comptable
professionnel agréé fondatrice de finale
source bonsoir
alors il ya plusieurs contribuables qui
ont encore bénéficié de prestations
fédérales en raison de la pandémie
qu'est ce que ces gens là doivent savoir
avant de faire leur déclaration de
revenus en fait je pense que les
personnes qui ont reçu des subventions
de regarder un des prestations pardon
doivent garder en tête trois concepts
premièrement toutes les prestations qui
ont été reçus sont imposables donc qu'il
faut absolument inclure ces montants là
dans nos revenus la deuxième chose il
faut se rappeler que notre système
d'imposition est basé sur le revenu
total et non le revenu partie poupart
source donc on va calculer leur revenu
total et après ça il ya des paliers qui
vont se va venir se greffer à ça pour
calculer l'impôt ce que ça veut dire
c'est que si on a eu des revenus
seulement 2 pc heureux les montants
d'impôts qu'on doive devoir payer
peuvent être assez similaire aux
déductions à la source de 10% qu'on a
reçus mais par contre si on a d'autres
revenus d'emploi qui sont greffés par la
suite montant de revenu va être
supérieur donc le montant d'impôt
devrait être supérieure et par
conséquent il faut s'attendre à payer
des impôts supplémentaires pour horreur
on a dû donner lui miley ne faudrait pas
s'en étonner donc si jamais on n'a de
l'info supplémentaire à payer sur nos
prestations l'an passé il ya eu des
délais de grâce qui ont été accordés aux
particuliers et aux pme aussi en lien
avec les prestations coville est ce que
c'est encore le cas en ce moment en
phase aller passer d'eux avait raison on
a eu des délais qui ont été dus ou fait
qu' il ya eu des remboursement de
prestations auxquelles les gens les gens
n'avaient pas nécessairement compris
alors que cette année je pense que les
vérifications déjà connu par ont déjà
commencé pour ses prestations lol les
gens sont au courant de l'imposition et
de l'impact de ces prestations là donc
on ne devrait pas s'attendre à des
délais supplémentaires surtout que la
grande surprise de remboursement par
exemple la pca heureux elle est connue
donc les gens qui au rang d'un revenu
supérieur à 30 milles vont s'attendre à
payer ce montant là parce que le
principe et le concept existait déjà le
needham j'aimerais qu'on parle un peu
des travailleurs autonomes et des
travailleurs à la demande également
ces gens là peuvent bien sûr faire leur
propre déclaration de revenus est-ce que
c'est plus compliqué non en fait les
travailleurs autonomes peuvent on peut
tous faire une déclaration d'impôts par
nous-mêmes mais c'est sûr que c'est plus
celles-ci on peut manquer en fait
certaines dépenses ou manquer le bateau
sur certaines choses ce que je peux dire
à des travailleurs autonomes par exemple
qui voudraient simplifié ou s'occuper
d'une portion il ya toujours la méthode
simplifiée pour la remise la tps tvq qui
peut aider à simplifier tout le côté
paperasse et leur permettre de faire un
bon bout de chemin déjà par romain par
contre si on passait des travailleurs
qui dans le domaine de la livraison les
propos nommer certaines compagnies
ouvriers tout autre à ce moment là il
faut penser aux dépenses qu'on en cours
par exemple la voiture mais il faut pas
penser à la dépense seulement qu'on
monte dans la voiture qu'on fait la
dépense il faut vraiment penser à
regrouper l'ensemble des dépenses dans
l'année et c'est pas principe de prorata
du kilomètre pour le travail versus le
kilomètre totale qu'on a parcouru dans
l'année qui va utiliser et non pas
seulement garder les reçus les dépenses
qu'on en cours au moment de faire les
livraisons ok c'est important on reçoit
de plus en plus de questions année après
année puis encore aujourd'hui on a reçu
des questions sur les crypto monnaie les
crypto actifs gelé déclare ou gelée
déclare pas et à quel endroit je fais ça
la loi n'est pas en quarts ajusté
complètement mais par contre les deux
guides qui existe chez moi sous wajda
mes clients j'ai quelques clients au
niveau de la crypte money ce que je dis
c'est c'est un peu comme la bourse dans
le temps on avait pas d'aidé des grandes
lignes très précise au niveau de la
crypte année c'est la même chose dit un
guide qui existent au niveau de revenu
canada et revenu québec est en fait le
principe demeure le même s'il ya des
critères qui ont été développés pour
dire est ce que c'est vraiment une
entreprise connaît ce qu'on a un projet
commercial il ya des critères qui sont
avancés et par la suite selon les faits
de chacun on est obligé de reporter que
ce soit un revenu d'entreprise ou du
gain en capital selon avec le haut il
faut les déclarer ça c'est une évidence
par contre est-ce que ça va être déclaré
comme un gain en capital imposable à 50%
ou est-ce que c'est du revenu
d'entreprise elle vous avez 100% donc
s'il ya une perte ou une perte de valeur
ça va être une affaire d'entreprise mais
définitivement que toutes les
transactions de cryptome n'est
matérialiser il est revenu récurrent
gagner comme les jouets etc doivent être
imposables kelly la déduction que la
majorité des gens oublient ou négligent
bay surprenamment l'année dernière j'ai
beaucoup de gens qui ont sous-estimé les
frais de dépenses à domicile parce que
dans leur tête c'était compliqué de
cumuler les différentes factures pour
entretenir chez les hommes il faut se
rappeler que la méthode simplifiée
existe de dollars donc s'il ya des
conditions qui existent plus de ce
travail à la maison plus de 50% du temps
de façon continue ce consécutive par
dans quelques semaines à ce moment là on
a un montant forfaitaire qu'on peut
appliquer qui est très rapide pour pour
les réclamations qui peut nous donner
jusqu'à 500 $ est le deuxième que
j'aimerais préciser qui est souvent
oubliée c'est le crédit remboursable
pour les enseignants et les éducateurs
en petite enfance c'est un montant qui a
été bonne iphone hybride fédéral et
c'est un crédit remboursable jusqu'à
hauteur de 250 dollars parfait on le
prend et on termine sur les adolescents
qui sont quand même de plus en plus
nombreux à travailler avec la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre est ce que ça peut avoir
un impact sur la déclaration des parents
oui en fait la déclaration des parents
pour est impactée dans une situation où
on a une famille monoparentale
l'adolescent habite avec sa maman et son
papa est souvent ces gens là vont
prendre l'adolescent à charge au niveau
fiscal et à ce moment là s'ils sont
revenus dépassent le 13 mille dollars 13
mille et quelques à ce moment là oui les
crédits pour les parents pourraient être
impactées il pour avoir un crédit
beaucoup plus bas à cause ou ou parce
que l'adolescent travail et un revenu
d'emploi dont il faut garder ça en tête
ok très intéressant merci beaucoup
myriam on va vous retrouver tantôt vous
aurez d'autres réponses à nos questions
avec les inc merci beaucoup aux attentes
quand il est question d'un pot certains
mythes sont tenus par exemple est il
vrai qu'avec une augmentation salaire
vous pourriez quand même vous retrouver
avec des revenus nets moins élevé la
réponse plus tard à l'émission
et après la pause que devez-vous savoir
si vous êtes à la retraite si vous êtes
retraités si vous êtes semi retraités
lorsque vous faites votre déclaration
d'impôts on a de bon conseil à vous
donner dans quelques instants
[Musique]
au cours de la prochaine de niort
spécial un pont de zones économiques
doivent savoir les retraités votre
salaire vous fait elle changeait de
palier d'impôts et nos experts répondent
à vos questions sur les impôts mais
d'abord on vous a demandé ce soir vos
impôts sont ils bien utilisé la plupart
des gens disent poliment qu'on pourrait
faire beaucoup plus c'est une question
censée régir alger sentiment d'émotion
dans une réponse qui nous sont parvenus
de la déception un peu de colère un
mélange de tout mais de manière générale
les gens pense effectivement qu'on
pourrait faire mieux martin deschamps no
10 est ce qu'on est ce que vos impôts
sont bien utilisés non il dit je suis
dans la catégorie qui fait le plus
d'impôts le 20 % et je n'ai même pas de
médecin de famille pour moi et mes
enfants c'est vraiment mal géré ce
système de santé c'est la cible de
plusieurs critiques d'ailleurs dans nos
commentaires france gervais nous dit non
c'est mal gérée en plus on est surtaxé
mais le gouvernement offre de l'argent
aux multinationales des enveloppes
disant vouloir protéger les emplois je
n'y crois pas il n'ya pas de suivi sur
les investissements mike smith lui nous
dit c'est surtout mal gérée si gérer mon
argent comme le gouvernement j'aurais
déjà fait faillite dix fois bon ça reste
à voir mais tout de même on sent
beaucoup scepticisme envers la façon
dont ces gérer et d'habits devait
remettre lui nous dit c'est incroyable
le gouvernement est trop gros beaucoup
trop de fonctionnaires les impôts sont
dans le tapis les services sont
médiocres il serait temps de couper dans
le gras réduire les services et surtout
réduire les taxes et les impôts et
d'autres soulignent qu on paie pour les
choix de société qu'on a fait exact on a
des services et ce n'est peut-être pas
toujours parfait mais effectivement ça
vient avec une certaines factures mon
éclampsie nous dit on ne fait le choix
au québec d'avoir un filet social qui a
moins de trous qu'ailleurs de mètres
avant de t'en place avant tout le monde
un réseau de cpe qui a permis aux femmes
de prendre leur place sur le marché du
travail
c'est pas parfait mais on oublie souvent
que nos services font l'envié d'autres
juridictions absolument tout à fait
merci beaucoup andrieu en attente au
maintenant que devez-vous savoir si vous
êtes retraité si vous êtes semi-retraité
au moment de faire votre déclaration de
revenus ce soir on reçoit qui me rendent
t2 ni ouailles canada bonsoir bonsoir on
va parler d'abord du supplément de
revenu garanti si les gens ont vu leur
supplément de revenu garanti baissé
parce qu'ils avaient touché des
prestations durant la pandémie est-ce
qu'ils ont une case à remplir ou un
formulaire a demandé dans leur
déclaration de revenus alors si vous
êtes admissible à recevoir cette
subvention pour prestations perdu leur
remboursement va vous est envoyé de
façon automatique par le même mode de
réception de prestations que vous
utilisez habituellement donc que ce soit
par dépôt direct ou encore par chèques
donc bonne nouvelle il n'y aura pas de
formulaire à remplir aucune case à
cocher et selon les informations
communiquées par le gouvernement les en
bois devrait se faire au cours de la
semaine du 19 avril la semaine du 19
avril donc vous avez perdu une partie de
votre supplément de revenu garanti
il ya une subvention qui existent elles
s'en vient dans la semaine du 19 avril
vous n'avez pas à cocher quoi que ce
soit parfait c'est précis on a parlé un
peu plus tôt de la bonification du
crédit d'impôt pour soutien aux aînés
mais c'est pas le seul crédit
intéressant pour les personnes
retraitées non effectivement il ya
plusieurs autres crédits qui peuvent
intéresser les retraités et qui pourrait
oublier dû au fait que ces crédits là ne
sont pas présentés distinctement sur
leur formulaire de déclaration de
revenus prenons par exemple au québec
les crédits dont je vais vous parler
doivent être réclamés sur la ligne
autres revenus qui est un peu un pot
pourri de toutes sortes de crédits donc
le premier crédit que j'aimerais vous
présenter c'est le crédit qui est relié
aux frais engagés par les aînés pour le
maitien le maintien de leur autonomie
donc c'est un crédit qui s'adresse aux
personnes qui sont âgés de 70 ans et
plus et là elle consistait à rembourser
20 % des frais encourus qui excède 250 $
dans ce que cela signifie c'est que si
vous payez vous dépenser 250 $ vous
n'aurez rien mais tout ce que vous
dépensez en excédent de ce 250 $ là vous
allez avoir un remboursement à
concurrence de 20 % les frais qui sont
admissibles ce sont des frais qui
peuvent être pour l'achat la location ou
encore l'installation de biens et
équipements qui assure l'autonomie de
l'un à l'autre
par exemple la subvention pour hausse
significative des taxes municipales pour
les 65 ans et plus oui en effet cette
subvention est également intéressante
elle s'adresse cette fois ci aux
personnes qui sont âgés de 65 ans et
plus et pour pouvoir se qualifier vous
devez avoir été propriétaire d'une
habitation pendant une période
consécutive de 15 ans et cette
application ne doit avoir été votre lieu
principal de résidence le crédit peut
s'élever jusqu'à 500 $ par année par par
année et par rôle d'évaluation pour
savoir si vous pouvez avoir droit à ce
crédit vous devez allez consulter votre
compte de taxes municipales 2022 et
certaines municipalités par contre ont
plutôt choisir de vous envoyer une
lettre distingue par la poste alors
surveillez également votre courrier
postal excellent et il ya un autre
crédit également pour activités
physiques artistiques culturelles ou
récréatives
oui tout à fait c'est lui là vise comme
vous voulez de mentionner vraiment
l'activité de nos aînés alors au service
des personnes qui sont âgés de 70 ans et
plus le crédit correspond à 20% des
frais qui sont encourues pour s'abonner
à des activités qui doivent durer au
minimum une période consécutive de huit
semaines ou encore une périodes
consécutives de cinq jours le montant
maximum du crédit est de 40 dollars dont
6 le coût d'inscription est de 200
dollars vous aurez à ce moment-là avoir
obtenu le maximum admissible pour ce
crédit
pardon c'est un crédit remboursable
il ya un crédit d'impôt également pour
revenu de retraite oui effectivement
pour nos retraités probablement qu'à
vous avez déclaré des revenus de
retraite à ce moment là vous aurez le
droit de réclamer le crédit pour une
retraite qui équivaut à un montant
d'environ 440 $ au québec est de 300
dollars au fédéral et aux deux paliers
par contre ce ne sont pas des crédits
remboursables ayant un crédit fédéral
pour revenu de pension
oui effectivement leurs écrits 10
fédéral pour un revenu de pension il est
à la hauteur de 400 dollars ok parfait
il nous reste un petit peu de temps pour
parler des projets dans le rôle d chez
d'un est reconnue bien sûr dans notre
société est ce qu'on peut demander
quelque chose en lien avec sa wii tout à
fait apte au québec qu'au fédéral il y à
une mesure qui vise à aider
financièrement les projets dans les
conditions sont un peu différente au
québec vous devez la personne aidée doit
être âgé de 70 ans et plus et vous devez
aussi cohabiter avec cette personne là
pour une période consécutive de 365
jours dont au moins 183 jours doivent
être dans l'année 2021 donc si jamais
vous vous qualifiez le crédit que vous
pouvez aller chercher au québec s'élève
à
1266 dollar et au fédéral le crédit
auquel vous pourriez avoir droit s'élève
entre 1102 à 1446 sauf qu'au fédéral et
les conditions sont différentes c'est à
dire qu'il n'ya pas de critère d'âge
premièrement mais on exige une condition
de déficiences soit physique ou
cognitive hockey une dernière question
que je pose elle vient du public hélène
lemire qui dit y a t-il un crédit
d'impôt fédéral fédéral pour les 65 ans
et plus qui continuent de travailler non
malheureusement le fédéral n'a pas prévu
prévu d'intel a aidé pour un aux
travailleurs expérimentés qui voilà qui
me right et merci d'avoir été avec nous
merci
après la pause vous gagnez plus vous
changez de palier d'impôts que va-t-il
rester dans vos poches
et plus tard mais rien de smirès et de
godbout et va répondre at devons
répondre à d'autres questions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais les vous de vos impôts on va
défaire un mythe ce soir andréanne une
augmentation de salaire peut-elle
vraiment nous faire perdre des revenus
si on change de palier d'imposition mais
pas s'étonner s'il ya des gens qui se
disent qu'est ce qui arrive si je
travaille plus d'heures dans une semaine
que j'ai une augmentation de salaire par
exemple parce que je change d'emploi ou
de mon employeur m'offre un meilleur
salaire donc si je génère plus de
revenus et que je change de palier
d'imposition est ce que je vais me
retrouver donc avec des impôts plus
élevés à payer sur l'ensemble de mes
revenus et en bout de ligne me retrouver
avec des revenus nets qui sont moins
importants plusieurs pensent que c'est
la réalité mais c'est faux en fait cette
croyance il ya deux raisons qui
expliquent ce mythe d'une part les
systèmes de retenue à la source pour les
systèmes de paix si vous travaillez par
exemple deux fois plus dans une semaine
on voit présumé dans le système que vous
avez doublé votre salaire annuel ça fera
beaucoup de retenue à la source tout ça
se corrige plus tard dans l'année mais
ça te donne l'impression aux
travailleurs qu'on gagne pas vraiment et
l'autre source de ce mythe c'est la
confusion souvent entre le taux marginal
d'imposition et le taux moyen est le
taux marginal je vous le rappelle c'est
celui qui est en vigueur sur chacune des
tranches jouets revenus donc plus on
augmente plus cette tranche de revenu
est imposée alors quelqu'un a
l'impression que s'il change de palier
d'imposition il va payer plus d'impôts
sur tous ses revenus alors qu'en réalité
c'est plutôt le taux moyen qu'on paie
qui est toujours inférieur au taux
marginal qui s'appliquent sur la tranche
la plus élevée de nos revenus par contre
les ménages peuvent quand même perdre
différentes prestations ces deux gagnent
davantage ce qu'ils sont perdants rendu
là c'est ça en fait il ya un certain
moment où chaque dollar de revenu brut
supplémentaire peut entraîner la perte
de prestations sociales pensée
allocations pour enfants près mon
travail remboursement de taxes par
exemple et il y à ce que les fiscalistes
appelle une zone douloureuse entre 40 et
50 mille de l'envoyer le palier
d'imposition semble assez stable or si
vous passez un certain seuil ou vous
perdez des prestations quand on calcule
tout ça ce que vous avez réellement dans
vos poches à chaque dollar de revenu
supplémentaire vous allez voir ce que
vient chercher le fisc c'est au-dessus
de 90 % jusqu'à un certain point pendant
sept période douloureuse la de revenus
mais de manière générale même si lente
est très peu dans les poches avec un
salaire plus élevé il en reste quand
même donc on n'est jamais à proprement
parler perdant dans la voix la douleur
la baule oui elle salue sûr c'est ça le
revenu supplémentaire vous en donne pas
au bout merci beaucoup à tout vent pluie
et la pose beaucoup de questions
beaucoup de réponses pour vous dans un
instant avec nos experts
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous coûte bouée meriam smirès sont de
retour avec nous pour répondre à
quelques-unes des très nombreuses
questions que nous avons reçu tout au
cours de la journée meriem lucre bonsoir
bonsoir première question pour myriam
j'ai eu 60 71 ans en mars 2021 nous dit
daniel des chéneaux est ce que est ce
que je devrais remplir ma déclaration
pour 2021 différemment de celle des
années précédentes
derrière sont déjà convertis en effet
réveillé en faire depuis quelques années
je fractionne mes revenus de pension
avec mon conjoint qui avait 64 ans à 21
en 2021 qu'en pensez-vous myriam en fait
une imitation effectivement qui existent
au niveau du fractionnement grenet pour
l'âge de 65 ans mais pour l'âge de 65
ans elle existe seulement pour le
pensionnat qui fraction sont revenus
donc étant donné qu'on atteint 65 ans
mais bien 71 donc strictement aucune
différence pour pour la déclaration
actuellement pour madame de chez nous
donc elle va continuer à fractionner
sont revenus c'est davantage en fait le
le conjoint qui après 65 ans qui ne peut
pas de son côté fractionné quoi que ce
soit qui doit attendre d'atteindre 65
ans surtout qu'au québec on ne peut pas
frattini le revenu six ans après 65
effectivement ok deuxième question de se
l'acheter pour lui que j 63 3 ans je
travaille depuis plusieurs années est ce
que j'ai droit au crédit d'impôt pour
prolongation de carrière car je
travaille dans une entreprise familiale
la question c'est vraiment entreprise
familiale donc la réponse courte c'est
non ce qu'il faut comprendre on voudrait
pas qu'un salarié qui soit lui-même un
actionnaire dirigeants puissent se
verser du solaire pour avoir au crédit
donc que ce soit sa propre entreprise
l'entreprise de son mari l'entreprise de
son frère sa soeur de ses enfants si un
lien de dépendance le crédit le salaire
n'est pas admissible au crédit
prolongation de carrière ok parfait
réponse claire meriam à votre tour une
question de raymond baril qui dit j'ai
déjà reçu l'avis de cotisation avant le
rabais de 500 $ il parle du crédit de
500 $ et 6 du gouvernement du québec je
dois payer un montant de plus de 1000 $
en impôts est ce que je vais recevoir un
autre avis soustrait de 500 $ ou je
soustrais moi même ce montant en fait
revenu québec a déjà annoncé que si
l'avis de cotisation avait déjà été
envoyé il ya un ajustement qui allait se
faire et si un remboursement il se
réfugie famille donc dans le cas de
monsieur barry tu pourrais simplement
pillé la halle le montant du moins de
500 dollars étant donné qu'il va y avoir
une autre vie de cotisation qui va et et
me dit si la famille mais comme le
disait en début d'émission ont pu aussi
rien faire le gouvernement va s'occuper
de votre 500 c'est ça effectivement mais
il faut pas oublier qu'il faut par
contre payer le solde dû avant le 2 mai
pour éviter des intérêts donc pour
simplifier si on ne veut pas payer la
totalité ans devrait payer le solde du
moins de 500 dollars le 500 $ sera pris
en charge par un âne une deuxième avis
de cotisation qui ont été mis par le
gouvernement effectivement lu qu est-ce
qu on peut bénéficier cette année d'un
report pour payer un solde du eric
labonté mieux eu des reports dans à
cause de la pandémie
c'était une mesure exceptionnelle les
choses exceptionnelles n'arrive pas tous
les ânes et donc non cette année il n'y
a pas de report qui de prévu
la date limite pour produire sa
déclaration
techniquement c'est le 30 avril mais
comme le 30 avril et 1 samedi nous avons
donc jusqu'au 2 mai pour produire et
aucun autre délai n'a été annoncée
parfait autre question pour myriam je me
suis séparée de mon ex conjoint en
décembre 2021 la déclaration de 2021 et
donc toucher nous avons deux enfants qui
sont maintenant garde partagée quels
sont les éléments importants à
considérer dans la déclaration de
revenus demande julien dubé
effectivement les déclarations de 2021
vont être touchés dont il ya plusieurs
éléments il va y avoir l'effet qu'on
doit faire une déclaration distingue
donc chacun des deux contribuables ou
des deux ex conjoints doit faire sa
propre déclaration ils n'ont reporté
leurs revenus de l'autre est également
c'est que dans la déclaration de chacun
est endémique scène garde partagée
chaque chacun des deux conjoints pour
reprendre est des enfants à charge donc
quand on a deux enfants c'est plus
facile chacun prend un enfant à charge
et ça nous permet d'aller chercher un
crédit supplémentaire de points comme
personne à charge est également il faut
se rappeler que les frais médicaux c'est
les personnes qu'ils à payer qui peut
les réclamer il ya également des règles
ans a plutôt au niveau des frais de
garde car les freegans doivent être
réclamés par les personnes qu'ils
appuyaient mais il faut que l'enfant
était avec la personne donc étant donné
qu'ils étaient déjà en couple peuvent
diviser moitié moitié mais par la suite
ça on est dans une séparation de sur
toute l'année faut vraiment que ce soit
les frais bio tron a payé pendant qu'on
avait la responsabilité c'est en vue de
l'enfant il ya d'autres éléments aussi
c'est que les allocations familiales
vont être impactés mais ça c'est le sien
quelqu'un qui soit un peu plus tard que
dans la déclaration heure de nyc qu'on
voit pas prendre le revenu familial mais
leurs revenus de chacun des deux
contribuables et la location formule ait
visé par deux étant donné que c'est un
des deux conjoints de les deux
contribuent à klaas knot en train de me
dire que fiscalement c'est pas simple
quand on sait par au pas du tout aucun
du tout
parfait
question suivante maintenant linke yade
qui dit je vis je suis propriétaire j'ai
64 ans je suis en arrêt de travail mon
fils qui est majeure habite avec moi
puis je mettre personne vivant seule car
je ne reçois aucun revenu de loyer cluc
la notion de recevoir ou non un loyer
nantes pas dans la logique ici du delà
du montant pour personnes vivant seules
pour avoir droit au montant pour
personnes vivant seules il faut
effectivement vivre seul toute l'année
il ya quelques exceptions si on vit avec
un enfant mineur on peut quand même
avoir droit pour montant pour personnes
vivant seules six ont avec un enfant
majeur qui va aux études à plein temps
ou un petit enfant qui vaut aux études à
plein temps on va également conserver le
montant personnes vivant seules donc
pour l'admission en question le seul
moyen d'avoir droit aux montants
personnes vivant seules il faudrait que
son fils majeur soit aux études à plein
temps sinon il n'y aura pas droit
parfait myriam une rétro pour équité
salariale reçu plus de trois ans après
un décès étaient imposables au fédéral
sinon que faire pour récupérer les
sommes déduites à la source demande
mario simon alors on n'est que rarement
capable de dire qu'un montant qui n'est
pas imposable toutes les questions qu'on
reçoit mais effectivement une rétro pour
équité salariale qui a été déterminé
c'est pas juste une notion de payer
sinon notion de déterminer d'un côté ce
que la date quand est-ce qu'on a une
entente en fait pour déterminer montant
de rétro si cette date est arrivé après
la date du décès donc je comprends que
là ça fait 3 1 à ce moment là le montant
n'est pas imposable est donc à ce moment
là ni dans les médias du bénéficiaire ni
dans les mains de la personne décider et
si la date est déterminé après le décès
ce n'est pas imposable mais si elle est
déterminée avant dé 6,7 un poseur
exactement avec imposables comme un
revenu gagné par la personne décédée et
si on a en fait les règles de déduction
à la source risque suivent les mêmes
règles que ce que j'ai une dira donc si
il ya une erreur de la part de
l'employeur on peut effectivement aller
faire une déclaration pour se faire
rembourser mais si le il faut vraiment
se
regarder la date de détermination de la
rétro pour définir si c'est taxable ou
pas dernière question céline bélanger
dit comment ce calcul le partage de
fractionnement de revenus de pension
pour des retraités l'udc ici quand même
une réponse un peu plus longue mais
c'est une question pertinente parce
qu'ils veulent et 45 secondes beaucoup
d'années qui s'y intéresse d'abord le
fractionnement lié fictifs il n'y a pas
vraiment de transfert d'argent entre les
conjoints mais la facture d'impôts elle
elle est positive et il ya vraiment des
impôts à payer pour le coup peut-être
inférieur mais payés différemment que
les conjoints c'est pour ça qu'on
demande aux deux conjoints de signer un
formulaire relatif à ce choix-là de
fractionné ou non qu'est ce qui rentre
dans le fractionnement certains revenus
de pension qui sont admissibles les
rejoint les régimes de pension agréés
les sommes d'un ferr denrées r ça va
être admissible ce n'est pas admissible
et des prestations publiques passion de
sécurité de la vieillesse régime des
rentes ça sera pas admissible et il
reste la question de large généralement
c'est au-dessus de 65 ans 65 ans ou plus
mais où fédéral lorsque ces des revenus
de pension de type régimes de pension
agréés
on peut le faire sans égard à l'âge donc
dès lors qu'on a un revenu de pension
agréés on peut le transférer en
fractionné une partie de son action
conjointe sans égard à l'âge je rappelle
aussi le maximum c'est 50% qu'on peut
transférer de nos revenus de pension
admissible le goût de booster clair
merci beaucoup myriam smir s merci merci
merci je terminais avec avec adrian
parce que les gens que vont peut-être
avoir des remboursements d'impôt est de
plus en plus de gens savent qu'ils vont
faire avec leur remboursement d'impôt on
estime ce à peu près les deux tiers des
contribuer qui devrait avoir droit au
remboursement d'impôt et h r block les a
sondé c'est à peu près le tiers
justement des contribuables qui savent
déjà qu'ils vont se servir de ce montant
là pour se garder la tête au dessus de
l'eau c'est-à-dire faire face au coût de
la vie rembourser des factures de carte
de crédit en profiter pour acheter
certains produits essentiels très peu
pour investir moins de 20% veulent
investir par exemple dans un reér ou un
celi est très peu aussi des eaux loir
s'offrir un petit cadeau ou à des
proches c'est 11% 12% vous en profitez
pour se payer des vacances et on
rappelle aux gens que ils peuvent
retrouver toutes les réponses sur notre
site web alors le rendez vous c'est sur
la page radio canada.ca barres obliques
impôts au pluriel 2022 vous allez
retrouver sur cette page là en fait des
réponses aux nombreuses questions vous
nous avez fait parvenir merci beaucoup
d'ailleurs c'est assez une facile de
naviguer la dendre regrouper les
audiences en catégorie coved immobilier
est née ecce terra alors des réponses
sur cette page réponses fournies par les
étudiants à la maîtrise en fiscalité mon
père ce qu'on remercie d'ailleurs les
étudiants qui étaient là partisans et
qui ont répondu donc aux questions tout
au cours de la journée c'était la
formule ça s'est très très bien passé on
les remercie bravo félicitations merci
andré à merci et merci à vous et bonne
soirée ados mer
[Musique]